welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and the Marvel's just ripped open a
door to Secret Wars and spoiler warning
because on the other side of that door
is someone who doesn't know the meaning
of no shirt no shoes no service Beast
has joined the MCU as Monica Rambo finds
herself on the other side of an
incursion gateway to cross through the
Multiverse into an X-Men Universe where
every ringtone sounds
like look we got to do a deeper dive
into what happens at the end of this
movie because the new rules this film
established is for incursions for the
origins of the Bengals aka the quantum
bands which you might have noticed
binary is wearing golden variants of in
that X-Men universe and how exactly the
MCU is crossing over to the fox era
X-Men gives us a lot of information for
what to expect for Deadpool 3 AKA
Deadpool vs Wolverine for Kang Dynasty
for Secret Wars and for future MCU Xmen
films by the way I'm so excited for new
Rockstar's live show this Thursday
November 16th at brain dead studios in
Los Angeles please come hang out with us
my Loki theories and my Mesto Theory
from W division just got you know kind
of slapped in the face this week so new
rock stars is like making me go on a
public apology tour I wish I was joking
it's going to be a lot of fun though
ticket info in the description and
please support us by grabbing one of
these Loki we're all going to die shirts
at nerd riot. shop or a shirt from our
Marvel's collection okay there are
really three new rules that the Marvel's
establishes in the MCU that are pretty
critical to understand where things are
headed on this road to Secret Wars one
the quantum bands control the FB of
SpaceTime in the MCU and that also
includes realities rule two incursions
can occur by the fracturing of the
teleportation grid meaning they can
happen anywhere and three the fox X-Men
universe is as adjacent to the MCU 616
as the Sony universes are okay let's
take the Bengals SL Quantum bands first
they really are the central McGuffin of
this movie when the bangal was
introduced in Ms Marvel Quantum bands
were one of the relics from Marvel
Comics so we assumed it might be but now
we know for sure the quantum bands are
mostly associated with the character of
quazar but they've been worn by several
characters over the years each of them
chosen by their creator the cosmic
entity of eon the wielders have included
quazar anilus phel and blue Marvel Eon
remember is the Godlike figure that
oversees time in the universe Eon is a
child of Eternity he's known for having
a sloppy head made of of materials
throughout history he was depicted in
Statue form in eternity's chamber in
Thor love and thunder Eon created the
bands billions of years ago and gave
them to a protector deemed worthy of the
title protector of the universe they
draw power from the quantum Zone a
dimension of cosmic energy and in fact
all the actual energy in the Marvel
Universe comes from there the mcu's
quantum realm so far has been depicted
as something different something based
more on the concept of the microverse or
sub atomica but the MCU is also double
dipped on it as a dimension with portals
through time and a dimension with
Quantum probability storm so who knows I
mean even in the Loki finale the TVA is
aware of a realm adjacent to 616 like
it's in their database so they're
clocking it but Eon and in the comics
also at one point gave these bands to
Kronos who was the father to allars who
used these bands with his wife suicide
to give birth to their sons Thanos and
AOS you know those guys in the MCU so
these bands are kind of like a Rosetta
Stone that connects many aspects of the
Marvel Universe early on in the Marvel's
film darbin says that these bands were
forged as a pair forged meaning
constructed with some intent Carol says
she assumed the quantum bands were a
myth a cre legend that they were used to
create every jump point in the unn
teleportation grid so think of the Bands
as keys that unlock bridges that link
distant points in space but also distant
points in time Camala reminds us that
the inscription translates to what you
seek is seeking you and when I
interviewed Iman valani about the
Bengal's ability to tear a hole in time
for Cala to go back to the year 1947 she
confirmed that Kamala going back in time
was part of Kang's plan for that
character so who forged these Quantum
bands in the MCU I don't know if it's
going to be Eon but it might be one of
the Kang variants or Kang Prime like he
could have given the ancient cre in all
future societies the keys to their own
destruction and their own forced meeting
with each other from across the
Multiverse you could say these bands
forger paved the road to Secret Wars and
every Universe has their own variants of
these keys because notice that binary is
wearing both of the quantum bands of
that X-Men Universe they are gold
colored she might not know it but Maria
AKA binary in this universe could be how
Monica gets back part of the fun of
snacks is having a whole bunch to pick
from and getting to find the perfect
snack in your pantry to suit your hunger
in that moment if you want your pantry
perfectly stocked for any snack
situation you should check out nuts.com
nuts.com is your One-Stop shop for
freshly roasted nuts dried fruit Sweets
and More they've got a wide selection of
gluten-free snacks organic snacks sweet
snacks Savory snacks so many snacks and
it is all crazy fresh too nuts.com
roasts their nuts and Pops their corn
the same it ships so when it reaches you
it's way fresher than it'd be if it had
been sitting on a store shelf for who
knows how long so we ordered a ton of
stuffff from nuts.com for around the
office dried mango chocolate covered
gummy bears and these bourbon
pecans oh my God it's like a handful of
decadent Thanksgiving dessert my friends
it is so good and right now nuts.com is
offering new customers a free gift with
purchase and free shipping on orders of
$29 or more at nuts.com rockstars so go
go go go check out all the delicious
options at nuts.com rockstars you'll
receive a free gift and free shipping
when you spend $29 or more this brings
us to our second Point incursions can
occur anywhere by the fracturing of the
teleportation grid which kind of like
saying anytime you drive on any Bridge
or interstate in the United States your
brain could explode these hexagonal
portals have been in the MCU through
Guardians of the Galaxy movies through
Avengers endgame we just thought they
were kind of the backdrop but no no no
they have been a dangerous game for the
civil engineers of the MCU to play each
one of them have drilled a hole in the
fabric of reality and a essentially
violated a law of Nature and by leaving
these holes open and drilling too many
of them all of reality could crumble
it's amazing it hasn't happened yet in
MCU history I submit to you that these
hexagonal grids have been truly designed
as doomsday devices and the shape of
this architecture as hexagons got to be
no coincidence folks the Marvels even
mentioned that it was a Witch hex that
gave Monica her powers and when Wanda
cast her spell to build a pocket reality
it took the shape of a hexagon shimmy
woo even wrote on the board why hexagons
a hexagon that gave Monica her powers
and hexagons she has to piece back
together to enter a new reality when
darb Ben used both Bangals to open the
rift in the distance you could see a
black hole and in Loki season 1 episode
6 black holes were shown as how he got
from one Universe to another we're
really seeing the Recon convergence of
Science and magic in the MCU which
you'll remember in the 2011 Thor film
reminded us were really two terms for
the same thing the MCU is just giving us
too many ways for the Multiverse to be
destroyed Doctor Strange is using two
extreme of magic with the Runes of kough
call the cre using the quantum bands to
too aggressively the TVA taking too long
of a bathroom break an incursion occurs
when the boundary between two universes
erodes destroying one or both entirely
we appreciate your concern Steven but
it's not the Scarlet Witch that we fear
from our experience the greatest danger
to the Multiverse it turns
out so it's really no one's fault that
the universe is collapsing it's set up
to Collapse by Kang prime or whoever is
bringing the Marvel heroes together in
secret Wars they want it to happen and
they're putting the Avengers the X-Men
the spider Heroes everybody on a
collision course and so our third new
rule that the Marvels establishes the
fox X-Men universe is as adjacent to the
MCU as the Sony universes actually in
Kevin feige's introduction to the MCU
timeline book he said on the Multiverse
note we recognize that there are stories
movies and series that are canonical to
Marvel but that were created by
different storytellers during different
periods of Marvel's history the timeline
presented in this book is specific to
the the MCU sacred timeline through
phase 4 but as we move forward and dive
deeper into the Multiverse Saga you
never know when timelines May crash or
converge hint hint spoiler alert so just
imagine on one side of the MCU doct
Strange's spell magic which Wong said
traveled the borders of known and
unknown realities erodes the boundary of
the MCU to the spider verses of Toby
McGuire Peter Parker Andrew Garfield
Peter Parker and Tom Hardy venom Eddie
Brock and then on the other side of the
MCU the quantum bands are eroding the
boundary of the MCU to the to the X-Men
universe that includes Hugh Jackman
Wolverine Patrick Stewart Charles Xavier
and Kelsey gramer beast and those are
just the ones we know of for sure but
this reality also has halleberry storm
James Marsden Cyclops thany Jansen Jean
Gray Rebecca Romain Mystique Ian mckel
and Magneto Anna pacin robe sha Ashmore
Iceman and Elliot page Kitty pride and
now we just saw Loki ending with Loki as
a god of stories figure who created his
own organic idril tree inspired timeline
line that allows Branch realities and
free will to coexist but I think this
guy is going to be at odds with Kang
Prime who views incursions as the death
of the Multiverse because none of the
kangs want to do the work of actively
tilling that Garden so I think the
battle lines of Secret Wars will be
Multiverse versus no Multiverse that way
each side could have a mix of Avengers
and X-Men and spider people and a mix of
heroes and villains God of stories Loki
and his team of Champions versus Kang
Prime in his team of Champions I think
the very first shots of that battle are
going to be fired in Deadpool three but
I want to hear from you how do you think
that battle line will be drawn follow
all three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me at EOS big
thanks to Gina AO for help writing this
video come to our live show on November
16th it's going to be a lot of fun I'll
see you next time bye
[Music]
everybody